[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you all right had a nightmare about take
forever to explain dawn some way off
we've got time
started in the guest room would care
more and I was relaxing that table and
next to me there is yennefer funny isn't
it
she's never been there seems so real in
my dream though was she
nagging you about something true to life
indeed we will find her in the dream I
went and found ciri and then we trained
those were the days
hmm little she-devil I've trained kids
who were faster stronger but none had
her character didn't end well did it
your dream no the Wild Hunt appeared
attacked Siri I couldn't move stood
there like a stump
it was just a dream that's the problem
it was more in the past when seaweed
appear in my dreams something was wrong
she was in danger we taught her how to
defend herself from anything wraiths
included
[Music]
be downing soon time to go
wait show me the letter from yennefer
might have overlooked some hint in there
didn't overlook anything we were meant
to meet in willoughby that's what she
wrote meanwhile one army or another
burned the village to the ground all we
can do is follow our trail so stop
talking for a minute and give me the
letter
hmm how about that it does smell of
lilac and gooseberries you were gonna
read it not sniff it they must meet soon
will it be near vizima hmm nothing else
to guide us there
what's this PostScript I still have the
unicorn
that's private very private uh-huh I
understand least I think I do maybe not
entirely but perhaps that's for the best
back on topic how's it look how far
behind Jennifer are we two or three days
trails fresh it looks like at least
towards the main road could be muddled
there
wait yeah that's I smell it
ghouls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of course when armies pass the Metro
[Music]
shut up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not too late to surrender
[Applause]
looking for a hunter named Nealon found
him what do you want
here about your notice I'm a Witcher
when'd you last see your wife
my gaze past fold on on my way after
hunt she were asleep we come back I'm no
soy never
notice anything strange maybe her
behavior
no she Rafi small himself nothing
different a link she's not run off if
that's what you're asking
maybe she went to the neighboring
village forgot to tell you no my sister
would never gone this thing before tried
looking for aster I'm the village nun
sourabh oh she must've left when they
were still sleeping told her time and
again not to wander off on her own she
never listened I must have some man
focus go with the woods
I'll look in the woods you might have
missed something ask around - she have
any friends
Hannah kept East herself mostly watches
the blacksmith's young uns are doings
and in the village Glenna the butcher's
wife she likes her best thanks I'll try
to find her but no promises
greetings you Glenna sorry but gristle
and marrow was always willing to sow and
he left a way to learn done carbonate
wanted to talk to you about Hannah here
you were friendly she come by Oh times
good talk
she seems strange lately any idea where
she might have gone
strange no a cheerful soul always if I'm
to judge it's the Wolves gotta mean howl
in the nights through lately even the
barons men are feared to come by
Hannah must have gone to the wood to
gather mushrooms maybe straight to
deepen the howlers goner
thanks farewell
Wow my dad used to make swords like
yours I touch it
it's sharp better not need to talk to
your father
I forged swords once now it's soit's a
nose for good arms you'll need to go to
novigrad wanted to ask you about Hanna
but she looked after your children no
that's why I'm here
she maybe tell you where she was going
or anything else she's healthy and we
are Aten
I saw her go to the forest with another
lady
it was dawn almost I've gone out so I
wouldn't wake the colour the forest
she's done for why a huge pack roams the
area none from the village dares go in
the forest
Newlands only one not afeared but then
he's a hyung did you get a good look at
the other woman no it was no she walked
in front of an Hanna I couldn't see
thanks farewell